This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanthu. When the New York Times showed that Donald Trump may have used a legal loophole to avoid paying federal income taxes for years, many people expected the self-destribe billionaire to be embarrassed. Instead, in a debate with Hillary Clinton, Donald Trump said, He didn't pay any federal income tax. So, if he paid zero, that means zero. That makes me smart. It got us thinking about a new book by Brooke Harrington, a sociologist at the Copenhagen Business School in Denmark.
这里是《隐藏大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。当《纽约时报》披露唐纳德·特朗普可能利用法律漏洞连续多年逃避缴纳联邦所得税时，许多人原本以为这位标榜自己的亿万富翁会感到尴尬。然而，在与希拉里·克林顿的一场辩论中，唐纳德·特朗普却说，他没有缴纳任何联邦所得税。所以，如果他交了零，那就意味着是零。这说明我很聪明。这让我们想起了丹麦哥本哈根商学院社会学家布鲁克·哈灵顿的一本新书。
She decided several years ago to explore the secret lives of billionaires. She took an unusual path to enter this world. She herself trained to become a wealth manager. In the course of this training, she gained unprecedented access to other wealth managers who agreed to be interviewed for her research. She discovered that in order to manage money for the super rich, these professionals also learn a lot about the private lives of their clients. What they shared, Brooke says, shocked her.
几年前，她决定探索亿万富翁们的秘密生活。她走上了一条不同寻常的道路来进入这个世界。她自己接受了成为一名财富管理师的培训。在培训过程中，她获得了前所未有的机会，能够接触到其他同意接受她研究访谈的财富管理师。她发现，为了替超级富豪管理资金，这些专业人士同时也深入了解了客户的私生活。布鲁克说，他们所分享的内容震惊了她。
The lives of the richest people in the world are so different from those of the rest of us. It's almost literally unimaginable. National borders are nothing to them. They might as well not exist. The laws are nothing to them. They might as well not exist. The laws are nothing to them. They might as well not exist. Today on Hidden Brain, the sociology and psychology of some members of the billionaire class and the professionals who enable them. Brooke Harrington, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you for having me on the show.
世界上最富有的人的生活与我们普通人的生活有着天壤之别。几乎可以说是无法想象的。对他们来说，国家边界根本不算什么。它们形同虚设。法律对他们来说根本不算什么。它们形同虚设。法律对他们来说根本不算什么。它们形同虚设。今天的《隐藏大脑》节目将探讨亿万富翁阶层中某些成员以及为他们提供便利的专业人士的社会学与心理学。布鲁克·哈灵顿，欢迎来到《隐藏大脑》。谢谢邀请我来节目。
For wealth managers to do their job, Brooke, I understand that they need to find out everything about a client's life, not just a client's financial life, but everything about their life. Give me some examples of the kind of conversations people have with wealth managers and the kind of issues they bring up about their personal circumstances that might affect how their wealth is managed. Well, it usually starts with what's called know your client activity. So, if you were to come to me with me acting as the wealth manager, I would first ask to see some proof of identity like your
布鲁克，为了让财富管理师做好工作，据我了解，他们需要了解客户生活的方方面面，不仅仅是客户的财务生活，而是他们生活的全部。能给我举几个例子吗？人们会与财富管理师进行什么样的对话，他们会提出哪些可能影响其财富管理的个人情况问题？嗯，这通常从所谓的“了解你的客户”活动开始。所以，如果你来找我，而我作为财富管理师，我会首先要求你出示一些身份证明，比如你的
passport. And then we would talk about what goals you had for your wealth, and that begins the series of increasingly delicate and increasingly intrusive questions. Then usually we get into whatever real reason is bringing you to me. Maybe you want to avoid your taxes. Maybe you really don't like your family. That's surprisingly common among wealthy people. For example, if you have a relative or if you yourself are engaging in some activity that might get you extorted, it may not be illegal, but it might be socially shameful.
护照。然后我们会讨论你对自己的财富有什么目标，这便开启了一系列越来越微妙、越来越具侵入性的问题。接着，我们通常会切入你来找我的真正原因。也许你想避税。也许你真的很讨厌你的家人。这在富人当中出奇地普遍。例如，如果你有一个亲戚，或者你自己正在从事某种可能会让你遭到勒索的活动，这可能并不违法，但可能会带来社会羞耻。
That's a financial risk that your wealth manager needs to know about. If you have a son or daughter with a drug problem, that's a financial risk that your wealth manager needs to know about. There can also be issues like, I think I'm headed for a divorce, but I don't want my spouse to get half my assets. How do I hide those assets? Preferably offshore, so that whatever is legally provable as mine is such a small amount that it's not worth fighting about. So it's really interesting because these professionals in some ways get to know their clients better than the client's own family or friends or even their own spouse? Yes, it's apparently something of a cliche in the offshore
这是你的财富管理师需要了解的财务风险。如果你有一个沾染毒瘾的儿子或女儿，这是你的财富管理师需要了解的财务风险。也可能会出现这样的问题：我认为我的婚姻走到了尽头，但我不想让配偶拿走我一半的资产。我该如何隐藏这些资产？最好放在离岸，这样在法律上能证明属于我的资产少到不值得为之争吵的地步。所以这真的很有趣，因为这些专业人士在某些方面对客户的了解甚至超过了客户的家人、朋友甚至是配偶？是的，在离岸
world that the average client is a man in his 50s with a secret family somewhere. Might be a gay lover, might be a common law wife and some children, but they're usually all sorts of secrets that these wealthy folks wish to keep hidden and that they have the additional privilege of being able to hire people to take care of in secret. So I understand you conducted about 65 interviews in 18 countries for this book. Tell me a little bit about the people you met. To be a wealth manager you have to understand finance and the law, but this kind of role also calls for a certain psychological makeup. What kind of person becomes a wealth manager?
世界里，这显然有点像个陈词滥调：普通客户是一个五十多岁、在某个地方有秘密家庭的男人。可能是个同性恋情人，可能是个事实婚姻的妻子和一些孩子，但这些富豪们通常都希望藏有很多各种各样的秘密，而且他们还拥有额外的特权，能够雇人秘密处理这些事情。据我所知，为了这本书，你在18个国家进行了大约65次采访。跟我聊聊你遇到的人吧。要成为一名财富管理师，你必须了解金融和法律，但这种角色也需要某种特定的心理素质。什么样的人会成为财富管理师？
Well, several of the people I spoke to describe themselves in only somewhat joking terms as social workers for the rich. So you have to have empathy and a desire to help people, but also a very high tolerance for people who would otherwise seem to be so extremely privileged that you might be otherwise inclined to smack them around and say snap out of it. You're lucky. You write in your book about the extreme lengths that some managers go to please their clients or to provide services to their clients.
嗯，我交谈过的几个人用半开玩笑的语气将自己形容为“富人的社工”。所以你必须具备同理心和帮助他人的愿望，同时还要对那些看起来极其特权、以至于让你原本想扇他们一巴掌说“清醒点吧，你已经很幸运了”的人保持极高的包容度。你在书中写到了某些经理人为取悦客户或为客户提供服务而做出的极端努力。
You write about a manager named Eleanor and, who said that one of her clients once called her from outside a restaurant in London. Tell me that story. So this is one of the first stories that I heard that really made my eyebrows raise. It was while I was training to be a wealth manager, Eleanor told this story over lunch of receiving a phone call from a client who was in another country saying, I've just lost my bracelet outside of a restaurant, helped me find it. And the client didn't identify the restaurant by name.
你写到了一位名叫埃莉诺的经理，她说她的一位客户曾从伦敦一家餐厅外面打电话给她。给我讲讲这个故事吧。这是我听到的最早的故事之一，它真的让我大吃一惊。当时我正在接受财富管理师的培训，埃莉诺在午餐时讲了这个故事：她接到一个身处异国的客户打来的电话，说：“我刚刚在一家餐厅外面弄丢了手链，帮我找找。”而且客户并没有说出餐厅的名字。
So imagine having someone call you from another country. I mean, obviously the country was identified identified but not anything remotely approaching a location. So you have to sort of marvel at the immaturity of the client expecting someone else to help her fix a problem like this. But Eleanor somehow did it. She determined where the client was and what exactly had been lost
所以想象一下，有人从另一个国家打电话给你。我的意思是，很显然这个国家是知道的，但根本没有任何接近具体地点的线索。所以你不得不对客户的这种不成熟感到惊叹，她竟然期望别人帮她解决这种问题。但埃莉诺不知怎么做到了。她确定了客户所在的位置以及具体丢失了什么
and got the local authorities on the case, found the bracelet and build the client for all the time and apparently the client was happy to pay. There are sometimes clients do make requests like this not because they are acting childish but because they actually have an ulterior motive. They actually want to test the loyalty or ability of the wealth wealth manager You tell the story of a wealth manager in Hong Kong named David. Yes, he got a call early on in his relationship with the client In which the client said that he was in Japan and he was Meeting with a Japanese gentleman who had expressed a desire for smoked salmon and that this client had promised him I think a thousand sides of smoked salmon straight from the factory in Scotland and was now calling David saying get me the salmon and David said well I'm your wealth manager not your fishmonger and the client said well today you're the fishmonger and so David
并让当地当局介入此事，找到了手链，并将所有时间成本记账向客户索取费用，显然客户很乐意支付。有时候客户会提出这样的请求，不是因为他们表现得幼稚，而是因为他们实际上有不可告人的动机。他们实际上是想考验财富管理师的忠诚度或能力。你讲了香港一个名叫大卫的财富管理师的故事。是的，他在与客户建立关系之初就接到一个电话，电话中客户说他在日本，正在与一位日本绅士会面，这位日本绅士表达了对熏三文鱼的渴望，而这位客户曾向他承诺过，我想是一千面来自苏格兰工厂的正宗熏三文鱼，现在他打电话给大卫说，给我弄到三文鱼。大卫说，我是你的财富管理师，不是你的鱼贩子。客户说，好吧，今天你就是鱼贩子。于是大卫
happens to know someone who knew the head of the smoke salmon factory in Scotland and he he fulfilled the client's wish. And the client later told him, I basically made up that story. I wasn't sitting across from a Japanese fellow who wanted a thousand sides of Smoksammon. I just needed to see that you had the connections and the will to do what I wanted when I wanted and not ask any questions. It was almost a test of his ability to jump and sort of perform this outlandish request, perhaps as a guide to sort of other requests that would come for the down the road. Exactly, and also it was a test of what kind of powerful social connections this wealth manager might have, because one of the wealth manager's roles is to set up private markets for deals. So it's not uncommon for them to have several clients, each of whom owns incredibly valuable
碰巧认识一个人，这个人认识苏格兰熏三文鱼工厂的负责人，于是他满足了客户的愿望。客户后来告诉他：“我基本上是编造了这个故事。我并没有坐在一个想要一千面熏三文鱼的日本人对面。我只是需要看看你是否有连接和意愿在我想要的时候做我想做的事，而不问任何问题。”这几乎是对他跳出常规、完成这种古怪请求的能力的测试，也许可以作为指导未来可能出现的其他请求的风向标。完全正确，这也是对这位财富管理师拥有什么样的强大社会关系的测试，因为财富管理师的角色之一就是为交易建立私人市场。因此，他们拥有多个客户并不罕见，每个客户都拥有极其宝贵的
real estate, art collections, yachts, and so forth. And since these clients are very, very concerned about maintaining their privacy, they don't want to list these things on the open market for sale. If they need to raise cash, they want to do the sales as quietly as discreetly as possible with as little public recording as possible. One thing that I got from your book is that there are important ways in which the very rich are very much like the rest of us and ways in which they're not. So wealthy people, unsurprisingly, turn out to have troubled marriages and wayward children, just like everybody else.
房地产、艺术品收藏、游艇等等。由于这些客户非常非常关心保护他们的隐私，他们不想把这些东西放在公开市场上出售。如果他们需要筹集现金，他们希望尽可能安静、尽可能谨慎地进行销售，并尽可能少地进行公开记录。我从你的书里得到的一点是，超级富豪在很多重要方面非常像我们其他人，但在有些方面又很不相同不出所料，富人们也有着烦恼的婚姻和不守规矩的孩子，就像其他人一样。
But wealth, you argue, can compound those challenges. Well, apparently it's not uncommon for the wealth manager to be asked to find or recommend rehab facilities for kids. Or a parent will ask a wealth manager to break some bad news to the next generation to his or her own children. Sometimes the wealth manager has to broker a truce between feuding family members. So one family member feels that they've been done by unfairly in the inheritance plan
但你认为，财富会加剧这些挑战。嗯，显然财富管理师被要求为孩子们寻找或推荐康复机构并不是什么新鲜事。或者父母会要求财富管理师向下一代、向他或她自己的孩子透露一些坏消息。有时财富管理师必须在结怨的家庭成员之间斡旋停战。因此，一位家庭成员觉得他们在继承计划中受到了不公正的对待
and has to be somehow brought back in so that they don't sue the family. The big risk here is if you have a disgruntled family member who sews, the lawsuit process in many countries makes public many, many private documents that would reveal the extent and nature of a family's wealth, all of which have been carefully guarded secrets. When we come back, I'm going to talk to Brooke about how the rich lead very different lives than you and I. They don't just eat differently and travel differently and live in bigger
必须以某种方式被拉回来，以免他们起诉家族。这里的巨大风险是，如果你有一个心怀不满的家庭成员并提起诉讼，许多国家的诉讼程序会公开许多许多会暴露家族财富规模和性质的私人文件，而所有这些都是精心保守的秘密。等我们回来，我将与布鲁克谈谈富人们如何过着与你我截然不同的生活。他们不仅仅是吃得不同、旅行不同、住在更大的
homes. They sometimes play by an entirely different set of rules. Stay with us. My guest today is a sociologist Brooke Harrington. She spent years trying to understand the lives of people who are so wealthy that they're able to circumvent the constraints of national laws and borders. In the course of her many interviews with wealth managers, Brooke talked to one professional in Switzerland who told her a revealing story. So this this wealth manager and her boss had been summons to a country outside of Europe by a client who was sending a private plane for them. She showed up at the Zurich airport with her boss waiting for this plane and she discovered that she'd left her passport back home in a different purse. And she said to her boss, I've got to go home and get my passport
房子里。他们有时完全遵循一套截然不同的规则。请继续收听。我今天的嘉宾是社会学家布鲁克·哈灵顿。她花了好几年时间试图了解那些富有到能够规避国家法律和边界约束的人的生活。在与财富管理师的多次访谈过程中，布鲁克与瑞士的一位专业人士进行了交谈，对方给她讲了一个意味深长的故事。所以这位财富管理师和她的老板被一个欧洲以外国家的客户召集过去，客户为他们派了一架私人飞机。她和老板一起出现在苏黎世机场等待这架飞机，却发现自己把护照落在家里的另一个钱包里了。她对老板说：“我得回家拿护照
because we're leaving Europe. And he said, don't worry about it. And she said, again, no, they're going to check my passport. They won't let me leave Switzerland, much less enter another country. I've got to go home and he said, no, really, don't worry about it. So she didn't say anything for their figuring, it would be his problem if she got refused the right to leave. Sure enough, the private plane pulls up, they get on it, nobody checks a passport.
因为我们要离开欧洲了。”他说：“别担心。”她又说：“不，他们会检查我的护照。他们不会让我离开瑞士，更不用说进入另一个国家了。我必须回家。”他说：“不，真的，别担心。”于是她什么也没说，心想如果她被拒绝离境，那是他的问题。果不其然，私人飞机停下来，他们登上了飞机，没有人检查护照。
It lands in this other country outside Europe, nobody checks a passport, they get into the private car sent by the client, they're taken to the client's home, they have their meeting, private car takes them back to the private plane, private plane flies them back to Switzerland, they get off the plane and go home. At no point has anyone encountered passport control or a customs agent. And this wealth managers comment was, the lives of the richest people in the world are so different
飞机降落在欧洲以外的这个国家，没有人检查护照，他们坐上客户派来的私家车，被带到客户的家中，他们开了会，私家车把他们送回私人飞机，私人飞机把他们飞回瑞士，他们下飞机回家。在整个过程中，没有任何人遇到过护照检查或海关官员。这位财富管理师的评论是：“世界上最富有的人的生活与
from those of the rest of us. It's almost literally unimaginable. National borders are nothing to them. They might as well not exist. National borders are nothing to them. They might as well not exist. The laws are nothing to them. They might as well not exist. It's potentially very, very dangerous. And I think she's right about that.
我们其他人的生活有着天壤之别。几乎可以说是无法想象的。国家边界对他们来说根本不算什么。它们形同虚设。国家边界对他们来说根本不算什么。它们形同虚设。法律对他们来说根本不算什么。它们形同虚设。”这可能非常非常危险。我认为她是对的。
You spoke with the wealth manager named Dieter. I think this was a German wealth manager who talked about how his job allowed him to shmuse with powerful people, but also in some ways discovered things about foreign countries before even the citizens of those countries would find out about those important things. Yeah, he was very proud of the fact that when he was working in Africa, he would have parties and the heads of state of the various countries he lived in would come to his house and he'd get them drunk, and they'd be spilling state secrets by two in the morning.
你采访了一位名叫迪特的财富管理师。我想这是一位德国财富管理师，他谈到他的工作如何让他与权贵们推杯换盏，但也在某种程度上比这些国家的公民更早地发现了关于外国的重要事情。是的，他非常自豪的一点是，当他在非洲工作时，他会举办派对，他所居住的各国的国家元首会来到他家，他会把他们灌醉，然后在凌晨两点时分他们就会吐露国家机密。
And then people like Catherine Graham, the late publisher of the Washington Post would call him up for advice. And you know, he could speak authoritatively about at least affairs in some African countries because he'd heard it directly from the mouths of the people who made those policies. It reminds me a little bit about what we learned when the Panama papers scandal broke. I kept seeing photos or drawings of the faces of people whose names turned up in the Panama papers and they were it was really a rogue's gallery of people from all walks of life as well as heads of state and corporate leaders. People who you would think have nothing
然后像《华盛顿邮报》已故出版人凯瑟琳·格雷厄姆这样的人会打电话向他征求建议。你知道的，他能够对某些非洲国家的事务侃侃而谈，因为他是直接从那些制定政策的人口中听到的。这让我想起了一些我们在巴拿马文件丑闻爆发时了解到的事情。我不断看到那些名字出现在巴拿马文件中的人们的面孔照片或画像，他们真的是形形色色的人，既有各行各业的人，也有国家元首和企业领袖。你会认为这些人毫无
in common with each other. But at one level, the fact that they are so rich gives them these very important things in common, which is to say, for them, national boundaries and laws are all optional. Taxes are optional. All forms of law are essentially optional at that level of wealth. So this has come up recently in the US presidential election when Donald Trump suggested that not paying federal taxes or avoiding federal taxes legally, I might add, for several years, made him actually someone who was smart.
共同点。但在某种程度上，他们如此富有这一事实赋予了他们非常重要的共同点，也就是说，对他们来说，国家边界和法律都是可选的。税收是可选的。在那种财富水平上，所有形式的法律本质上都是可选的。所以这最近在美国总统大选中被提出来，当时唐纳德·特朗普暗示，多年来不缴纳联邦税或合法避开联邦税（我得补充一下），实际上使他成为了一个聪明人。
He didn't pay any federal income tax. So if he paid zero, that means zero. As you tell me about these very rich people, drawn from different walks of life who have this thing in common, the fact they're very wealthy, talk a little bit about their attitude toward taxes, and their attitude and obligations in some ways to footing the common bill.
他没有支付任何联邦所得税。所以如果他付了零，那就意味着零。正如你向我讲述的这些来自各行各业、有着“非常富有”这一共同点的超级富豪一样，请谈谈他们对税收的态度，以及他们在某种程度上对分摊公共开支的态度和义务。
Some of them actually do sound a lot like Donald Trump. When I heard Donald Trump say that not paying taxes made him smart and that if he had paid his taxes, they would have been wasted anyways. I was like, yep, he's the voice of a lot of very wealthy people around the world and their wealth managers who said essentially the same thing to me. They are very committed to neoliberal ideology and very committed to the idea that these elite clients are doing the world a favor as, as wealth creators.
他们中的一些人听起来确实很像唐纳德·特朗普。当我听到唐纳德·特朗普说不交税让他显得很聪明，而且如果他交了税无论如何也都会被浪费掉时，我就想：没错，他是世界各地许多超级富豪及其财富管理师的代言人，他们对我也说过本质上完全相同的话。他们非常坚定地奉行新自由主义意识形态，并坚信这些精英客户作为财富创造者是在为世界做贡献。
And that their initiative should be protected against the, the governments and, and what they regard as theft by taxation, by incompetent governments that would just waste any money they collected anyways. They also, by the way, regard redistribution of collected tax as immoral, because it creates dependency on the part of the poor. So I'm fascinated because what you're saying is that,
他们的主动性应该受到保护，免受政府的侵害，免受他们所认为的无能政府通过税收进行的“盗窃”的侵害——这些无能的政府无论如何都会浪费他们收集到的任何资金。顺便说一句，他们还认为重新分配所征收的税款是不道德的，因为它会造成穷人的依赖性。所以我很着迷，因为你的意思是，
in effect, the wealthy and their tax managers don't just think they're doing something that's practical and expedient, you're saying they actually feel like they're doing the moral thing? There is a very strong component of ideology here and you see this in the wealth management training program, you see it among at least about a quarter of the people I interviewed really seem to believe quite unironically in the justice of protecting the wealth of their clients from taxation. They literally view taxation as theft and they view government in general as being incompetent at best, corrupt at worst, and they're deeply suspicious of any sort of welfare state programs because they see it as destroying initiative.
实际上，富人及其税务经理不仅认为自己在做一件务实且权宜的事情，你是说他们实际上觉得自己在做一件符合道德的事？这里有一个非常强烈的意识形态组成部分，你在财富管理培训项目中可以看到这一点，你在我采访的人中至少大约四分之一的人身上也能看到这一点，他们似乎非常真诚地相信保护客户财富免受税收侵害是正义的。他们字面意思上将税收视为盗窃，他们普遍认为政府往好了说是无能，往坏了说是腐败，他们对任何形式的福利国家项目都深表怀疑，因为他们认为这会摧毁积极性。
So the picture you've painted for me broke of the wealth manager, someone who is a loyal person, an honest person, a resourceful person, trustworthy, and I fully imagine that lots of wealthy people are probably very good people, high-minded people, but I want to talk for a moment about the professionals whose clients are very clearly, you know, sleaze bags. How do you as a wealth manager serve the interests of someone who is cheating his country on taxes, cheating on his wife, cheating his employees? How do you serve a client like that and then go home, tell yourself that you're a good person and sleep well at night?
所以，布鲁克，你为我描绘的财富管理师形象是一个忠诚的人、诚实的人、机智的人、值得信赖的人，我完全可以想象许多富人可能都是非常好的人、高尚的人，但我想花点时间谈谈那些客户很明显是（你知道的）败类的专业人士。作为一名财富管理师，你如何为一个在税收上欺骗国家、对妻子不忠、欺骗员工的客户服务？你如何为这样的客户服务，然后回家告诉自己你是个好人，晚上还能安然入睡？
Well, some of them don't, and I think that's one of the reasons why we're seeing a wave of leaks recently, that some people are so troubled by what they're seeing that they just can't stomach it any longer, and they blow the whistle, often with dire personal consequences. About a quarter of the people I interviewed, I would characterize as being conscious stricken about the larger impacts of their work. And they had a range of strategies to reconcile themselves, to the implications of that for their own conscience. One of the ways that they dealt with it
嗯，有些人做不到，我认为这就是为什么我们最近看到一波泄密潮的原因之一，有些人对他们所看到的一切感到如此困扰，以至于他们再也无法忍受，于是他们站出来吹哨，这往往会带来可怕的个人后果。在我采访的人中，大约有四分之一的人可以被描述为对工作产生的更广泛影响感到良心不安。他们有一系列策略来调和这一点对其自身良心的影响。他们处理这种情况的方法之一
was to encourage their clients to donate to charity, to offset the negative impact of depriving the state of revenues. Other people I interviewed, including one gentleman in Panama City, said he would actually lecture his clients on the work of a Marchus N and Joseph Stiglitz, basically on the theory and practice of inequality in the world. And he would point out to them that as they sat in his office in Panama City, a couple miles away, people were living in cardboard shacks and had no access to clean drinking water.
是鼓励客户向慈善机构捐款，以抵消剥夺国家财政收入的负面影响。我采访的其他人，包括巴拿马城的一位绅士，说他实际上会给他的客户上课，讲阿马蒂亚·森和约瑟夫·斯蒂格利茨的著作，基本上是讲世界上不平等的理论与实践。他会向他们指出，当他们坐在他巴拿马城的办公室里时，几英里外的人们正住在简陋的纸板屋里，连干净的饮用水都没有。
And what did the client think about that? Now, that may seem mild, but it's a fairly risky strategy to pursue with wealthy people who are used to having people fall over them and not challenge them. And frankly, most wealth managers are replaceable. There aren't a lot of them in the world, but if you find one a little too in your face, you could always go get another one or get another one within a different company. I think a lot of people have impressions of the lives of the very wealthy and imagine what
客户对此作何感想？现在，这听起来可能很温和，但对于那些习惯了别人对他们阿谀奉承、从不挑战他们的富人来说，这是一种相当冒险的策略。坦率地说，大多数财富管理师都是可替代的。世界上并不缺这样的人，但如果你发现某个管理师太针锋相对、当面顶撞，你总可以换一个，或者在另一家公司再找一个。我想很多人对超级富豪的生活都有着某种印象，想象着当你坐着私人飞机四处飞、时刻有服务人员伺候时，生活一定是什么样子的。我在想，在与财富管理师的对话中，你对财富与幸福之间关系的任何假设或信念，是否得到了证实或挑战？我印象深刻的是我在海峡群岛交谈过的一个男人，他谈到了富人是多么猜疑。这与我个人看到的一些事情不谋而合。他说的是，当你真正富有的时候，有一种经历并不罕见，那就是每个人都想从你身上捞到好处。就像我们的许多彩票得主身上发生的事情一样，各种所谓
life must be like when you're jetting around in a private plane and being waited on by service staff all the time. And I'm wondering in your conversations with wealth managers, whether any of your own assumptions or beliefs about the connections between wealth and happiness were either confirmed or challenged? I was struck by a man I spoke to in the Channel Islands who talked about how suspicious wealthy people are. It jibed with some things that I've seen personally. And what he said was, when you're really wealthy, it's not uncommon to have the experience that everyone is out to get a piece of you. It's like what happens to a lot of our winners, all sorts of so-called
的亲戚从四面八方冒出来，请求贷款，请求某种帮助。骗子们从四面八方冒出来，想要从你身上分一杯羹。但在富人的一生中，这种情况不断发生。因此，它滋生了一种猜疑。你为什么想跟我交朋友？你为什么对我这么好？你是不是只是想让我给你点什么？
relatives come out of the woodwork, asking for loans, asking for help of some sort. Con artists come out of the woodwork, looking to get a piece of you. But that's what happens throughout the lifetime of wealthy people. And so it breeds a kind of suspicion. Why do you want to be my friend? Why are you being nice to me? Are you just trying to get me to give you something?
那一定很不愉快。你可以看出，这在极端情况下会导致类似于霍华德·休斯式的退缩或与世隔绝，因为如果你不能信任任何人，又何必去尝试呢？我的意思是，你所说的一个悲惨事实是，财富管理师最终可能成为富人极少数能够信任的人之一。是的，我想这似乎是一个普遍的故事。富人和他们的仆人。
And that must be very unpleasant. And you can see how that would lead at the extreme to a sort of Howard Husey and retreat or isolation from people, because if you can't trust anyone, why bother? I mean, the sad thing that you're saying is that the wealth manager might end up being perhaps among the very few people that a rich person can trust. Yeah, I think that seems to be a common story. It's wealthy people and their servants.
它几乎发展到这样一种地步：如果你是个富人，你对花钱雇来为你服务的人的信任，甚至超过了对那些不用付钱的人的信任，因为对于家人，你可能会遇到一种更棘手的问题：我的哪个孩子是真心爱我，哪个孩子只是想从我这里捞到好处。但至少当你与雇员维持一种交易关系时，那里的界限是清晰的。你为某些服务付钱，你可以评估他们是否在以你要求的标准提供
It almost comes to the point where you can, if you're a wealthy person, you are more trusting of the people you pay to be in your service than the people you don't pay because with your family you might have sort of a kinglier problem, which of my children actually loves me and which are out to get something from me. But at least when you are having a transactional relationship with an employee, at least the boundaries there are clear. You're paying them for certain services, and you can assess whether they are giving you
这些服务。如果他们没有，你就解雇他们。如果他们做得好，你就留用他们。这种简单性是情感关系中所不具备的。布鲁克·哈灵顿是丹麦哥本哈根商学院的社会学家。她也是《无国界资本：财富管理师与百分之一》一书的作者。布鲁克，我想感谢你今天与我交谈。谢谢。本期节目由玛吉·佩曼和帕特·查制作。我们的团队包括塔拉·博伊尔、珍妮·施密特、雷娜·科恩和雷妮·克拉克。本期我们的无名英雄是迈克尔·柯伦。迈克尔是NPR的音频
those services at the standard you require. If they're not, you fire them. If they're doing a good job, you keep them on. There's a simplicity to that that is not present in emotional relationships. Brooke Harrington is a sociologist at the Copenhagen Business School in Denmark. She's the author of the book Capital Without Borders, Wealth Managers, and the 1%. Brooke, I want to thank you for talking with me today. Thank you. This week's show was produced by Maggie Penman and Parts Cha. Our team includes Tara Boyle, Jenny Schmidt, Raina Cohen and Renee Clark. This week our unsung hero is Michael Cullen. Michael is one of NPR's audio
工程师之一，也是那个似乎知道如何解决我们遇到的每一个技术难题的人。这周他花了好几个小时来排查我们与布鲁克·哈灵顿所在的丹麦工作室之间的连接问题。迈克尔，感谢你以如此亲切和冷静的态度帮我们解决技术故障。我们真的很感激。如果你喜欢这期节目，请确保你订阅了本节目，并请把节目推荐给可能喜欢它的朋友。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆，这里是NPR。
engineers and the person who seems to know how to solve every technical challenge we have. This week he spends several hours troubleshooting our connection to the Danish studio where Brok Harrington is based. Michael, thanks for fixing our technical woes with such a kind and calm demeanor. We really appreciate it. If you liked this episode, please make sure you are subscribed to this podcast and please tell a friend who might enjoy this show. I'm Shankar Vidantam and this is NPR.
我们是。本集尚无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。
We are. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
是的。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。